the 100th episode in the series of
football life there in the century mark
this Friday night did you did you know
that I did not know it's indeed 100th
episode of a football life on the NFL
Network 9:00 Eastern Time on Friday and
it's John Randall's football life and
the Pro Football Hall of Famer joins me
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
John I'm doing fine better for chatting
with you how are ya all life's good with
you John yes okay where do you live in
the offseason or regulars from now that
you're of now no longer a player where
do you live John okay
so do you believe in the Vikings this
year just like everybody up there John
of course I do
I believe purple manna come on no I know
that but I mean as they're currently
constituted case keen and the whole
thing you think they can go the distance
John Randle you know player me being a
former player I look at one gamer time
but for overall yes I do
I believe it you know this game it
wasn't a game that they lost I look at
it as a game that wasn't a blowout it
was a closely fought game and I think
the mistakes that they made were minor
mistakes that they can easily correct
and get right back on track okay John
Randall Hall of Famer joining me here on
the show let's talk about your football
life what am I gonna learn have you seen
it by the way have you seen I think I'm
gonna wait and watch it with my family
so we can all watch it together
I normally don't like watching myself on
TV even a old track for myself I don't
like watching it but I want to watch it
with my family just see their natural
reaction of it okay what do you hope
that they learn what do you hope that
everybody learns about you from the show
from it about me how I was so different
from what they saw on the football field
my upbringing because my old childhood
home was torn down but NFL Films reached
restructure of reconstructed in
Philadelphia at the studios and me and
when I first saw it I wouldn't believe
it that they had done it such a close
resemblance of Solomon but before you go
on here so you mean you're to Mumford
Texas where your hometown is that you're
saying your yeah okay yep so what do you
mean they recreate it they rebuilt it
they rebuilt inside of it it made a set
that man I mean it was just so real and
when I went back and saw it you're going
to see me really get emotional because
it was almost identical to what I grew
up in as a kid I mean down to the black
and white television the little things
that they did with details and now
you're Pro Football Hall of Famer let's
talk a little bit about that football
journey from Trinity Valley Community
College to Texas A&M
university-kingsville and suddenly you
get dragged you get taken into the
National Football League by the
Minnesota Vikings what was it like
walking into that locker room in 1990
John I can remember riding over to win
apart and giving out the car with a
bunch of other rookies free agents we
walk off in there and they were kind of
telling guys you know what position guy
would go running back over there guys
there's linebacker over there and then I
walk up 245 245 pounds and say leave
muscle I'm they were like oh no no no
you're not go you're not gonna make it
at that so oh that was you know was part
of my journey you know coming in and
backing up Chris Dolman Henry Thomas
Keith Millar and al Nova these pretty
much all pro guys and maybe an unknown
guy you know most people would have
given me a chance of noting that the
making it man
I can remember I had to do my first
interview with a reporter and reporters
exact words were that he wanted to talk
to me because I was supposed to be there
for about a week then as well release me
now again now you're in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame John Randle joining me here
on the right rise to show a couple more
minutes with with him who was the the
toughest you ever had a face John oh I
practiced was Wendell McDaniel mm-hmm
and she was such a such a nice guy off
the field put on the field and he taught
me a lot because she told me he goes
either going against me you're either
gonna get better or you're gonna get
worse so every day it was a battle I had
to go through against his All Pro
Bowlers and he made me better but as an
opponent the best was Larry Allen Dallas
Cowboys Wow I made sure Vince Preston
692 pounds Larry Allen he's a madman
when did you first start putting the eye
black all over your face and barking
like a dog before the game John that
started out I think maybe for 95 season
we counted it fell into something and me
being very superstitious I kind of we
fell into it and I put in the game I got
three sacks and I said I got these sacks
doing it I had to continue to do that
because I was a very superstitious
did you ever legitimately scare somebody
legit yeah you know I actually scared a
couple my teammates because they
definitely knew Europe your teammates
goes in the shower before the game fully
closed pours water down his back on his
face and he's painting his face all
black yeah chatter he's kind of distance
me away from some of my team Richard
question your judgment a little bit I'm
saying but you know I think season went
on guys started understanding it I think
Mike type the time was one of my
teammates
the guy who always looked forward to be
putting on eye black
he needs to always tell me hey where's
your eyes left hey it's Johnny
we're sorry black so this we can just
you know to some ritual and just a
normal process for me
who's the Badger last one for you John
Randall who is the best pass rusher in
the National Football League today who
he thinks the best at it you know
several different tackles out there that
I really like you know and Donelson but
I gotta go with everything because his
energy after the shot and and I cannot
come closer
I've talked to him on several occasions
and I just he reminds me of me so much
with the energy because most guys you
don't really seem like they're having
fun
and ever is always back there having fun
and playing a game the way it's supposed
to be played okay you remember the first
time we ever met John no you know
remember that you remember shooting in
SportsCenter commercial a y2k
SportsCenter commercial yeah for you
were mild you're my office yeah well we
had a generator we were playing some
sort of game and you were eating peaches
out of a can John Randle yeah yeah you
just don't remember it was me cuz I had
all that hair you look the same
yeah you're not supposed to say Gary
you're supposed to say I look great
right now John that's it supposed to say
[Laughter]
okay have a great football live on a
viewing party on Friday with your family
John thanks for joining thank you you
got it Friday 9:00 Eastern Time on NFL
Network so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience